♪ [music] ♪
Our Mind
Investigation about Alzheimer's
disease in the Latino Community
- [Alex] Welcome to the first episode in
Spanish of the Brain Channel.
My name is Alex Figueroa, and we will be
talking about the Alzheimer's disease
and Dementia, specifically
dementia amongst Latinos.
With us today is Dr. Soria-Lopez.
Dr. Soria-Lopez is
an associated neurologist,
member of the memory team and an
investigator here at UC San Diego.
He is originally from Cuba. Dr.
Lopez studied medicine at the
Johns Hopkins University and ended up
here at UC San Diego.
and if you would like to tell us a little
So thank you very much
for being with us Dr. Lopez.
Tell us a bit more of how you ended
up here at UC San Diego?
- [Dr. Lopez] Thank you.
Thank you, Alex, for having me over to
talk about this subject which is
very important. I was always interested in
neurological processes and diseases,
when I was younger, so,
further on, I got more interested
in the medical profession,
seeing patients, seeing people and,
later on, in med school,
I decided to specialize in Neurology.
And, more recently, that led me to get
involved in and learn about the processes
of dementia, especially of Alzheimer's,
and that's what I do right now.
My interests in this disease and this
process, come from my interest in memory,
in cognitive processes,
how can they improve and how they are
affected by diseases of this type.
- Okay, great, thank you
for being with us.
So, probably, the most important question
right now is: What is Alzheimer's disease?
- It's a very important question.
Defining the illness.
The illness is a dementia disease which
manifests slowly, step by step.
It manifests with cognitive problems,
specially a slow and progressive,
mostly and especially, of the memory.
Other cognitive areas that are also
affected include language,
spatial orientation, time and
place orientation. And it is a slow
process, and it's progressive.
- Okay. And what are some signs
that can let us know when our
family members are suffering
from that disease?
- The disease presents itself, generally,
further on in life. The more we age
odds are higher of developing the illness.
One of the things that could be noticed
at first are loss of memory. People might
forget conversations they had.
They tend to repeat the same
conversation, the same questions
several times. They lack orientation from
the place they are in, to the time,
the hour, the day of the week. And,
at first, it's very mild.
It's not noticeable at first, but it
progresses. It's progressive.
- Okay, so, the symptoms
are much more serious
than, let's say, forgetting where
you put your car keys,
or forgetting an appointment,
simple things like that.
- Exactly, that is correct, Alex.
The symptoms...
Usually, if a person forgets,
they are distracted during the day
or night, at home, where they put their
things, where they put their keys,
but they can analyze and find their keys
later, taking their time, focusing.
That, in itself, is not a degenerative
memory issue or dementia.
It's more serious.
it would be a case where the person can't
keep up with their daily activities.
They can't continue doing their job.
They lose the ability to do more
instrumental activities,
like controlling their bank accounts,
driving properly without getting lost.
Those are the symptoms that may present.
- Okay. And how is that this disease
is affecting the Latin population
compared to other populations?
- What we have noticed, Alex,
with Dementia,
specifically in Alzheimer's,
is that when we look at various Latino
populations in the United States,
even in California and locally,
we find that it is more frequent
in the Hispanic population, compared
with non-Hispanic populations in the U.S.
- Okay. And what is being done
to combat this problem?
- There are…
Since, we are realizing,
and seeing the results that show that
the illness is more frequent in the
Hispanic community, we are conducting
clinical studies on how it is that the
disease is presenting in Hispanics,
compared to non-Hispanics.
How does it begin and why is it more
frequent, and why does it tend to be more
severe in the case of Hispanics?
- It sounds like it is a serious problem
affecting the Hispanic population.
So I think it is very important to educate
Hispanics about this problem
so that they'll to recognize these
abnormal changes happening
to them or their family members, so that
they'll be prepared to fight this problem.
- Absolutely. The process of Dementia
and Alzheimer's, when it occurs
and manifests and progresses, it is,
in itself, a tragedy.
And recognizing the initial symptoms,
making it more familiar,
having more knowledge of what the
disease is, allows us, especially in the
Hispanic community,
to identify it at an earlier stage,
and get advice, help, information,
about this process.
- Yes, for example, my grandmother
suffered from Alzheimer's,
and it took us some time
to realize that something was going on
because I think that in the
Hispanic culture, a lot of the time,
when there are any memory changes
we say, "Oh, it's because of their age."
We don't think it could be Dementia
because most of the time,
we don't know what Dementia is.
So, I think it is a big issue, and we are
trying to help all Latinos, right?
- Yes. Yes, Alex, and,
like you said, it's not… sometimes we
think that memory issues,
to have progressive memory loss,
to forget things is a phenomenon of
aging, but it's not a phenomenon of aging.
Experiencing memory loss,
asking the same questions several times,
repeating conversations several times,
to lose the ability of being time and
place oriented, it's not normal and we
shouldn't take it as a sign of aging,
because it is not. It is not.
There are other, more subtle,
changes of aging, but they are not the
ones of Alzheimer's.
- Okay, and speaking about my grandmother,
is this disease something that can be
inherited from parents to their children?
Is there a genetic component
to the disease? How does that work?
- In most cases,
Alzheimer's disease, Dementia,
aren't necessarily
inherited directly from the parents.
The disease itself is a biological process
where there are genes and biological
components that explain the disease,
but what we see is that,
in the majority of the cases,
it's not a process which is
inherited directly, dominantly,
to the children. With that, actually,
there are more particular cases in which
the disease presents itself
at an earlier age, it is called
Alzheimer's that occurs in young people.
Those are less frequent cases,
but some of those cases do manifest as a
genetic character that is passed on from
the fathers to the sons,
or the mothers to the daughters too.
- Okay. And when we were talking about how
to fight off this big problem that is
affecting us, you mentioned
the clinical studies.
Could you talk a little about the
importance of getting involved in the
clinical investigations and how
these investigations work?
- Yes, Alex, that is
a very important question.
Right now there are ways to look for help,
to look for information and access
to clinical studies
that include Hispanics.
The way to do it is
through the Alzheimer's organization
in San Diego,
"Alzheimer's San Diego",
that's the Alzheimer's association more
on a national level.
There also are… Those are two centers
where you can look for information about
the disease and you can… There are ways
to do it. You input your information
and they look for clinical studies
the person qualifies for.
Part of those clinical studies are
conducted on a local level,
on a state level, and on a national level,
and are also part of my duties
at the university.
- Okay. And, as you were saying,
Latinos are suffering
more with this disease.
I think it is really important
for Latinos to be involved
with these clinical studies, right?
And do you think that there are more
difficulties when trying to get more
Hispanics into this clinical studies?
- Yes, yes. I do believe so,
Alex, that it is more difficult.
It is important to include Hispanics in
the studies because we don't know
for certain if Alzheimer's disease is
the same in non-Latinos than in Latinos.
We are realizing that there are
differences, and the way to understand the
differences and how those differences
could affect the treatment in one
population or the other,
the way to discover that is having our
participants...a Hispanic component
to be able to compare Hispanics
and non-Hispanics.
- And to be able to know exactly what
the problem is, right?
- To find what the problem is.
We have an idea. For example,
in the Hispanic community...
one of the observations we've made
on the Hispanic community
with Alzheimer's, is that there is a
process in which the brain is being
affected by Alzheimer's in a similar
way than those non-Hispanics.
But Hispanics, we're finding in
several studies, have an additional
component in their brain,
a cardiovascular component that includes,
we've found strokes, heart attacks,
a little more frequently,
compared to those non-Hispanics. That,
along with the Alzheimer's process,
could make the person develop Dementia
maybe a little earlier and more severe
than what we expected.
- Okay. And, maybe, after hearing
about all of this,
a lot of people might be really worried.
So, my next question is,
is there something that can be done
to prevent Alzheimer's?
- Right now, there isn't a specific way to
completely stop and reverse the process.
We are working on finding ways of
slowing down the process so that the
person can be more comfortable,
with less clinical symptoms for longer.
There are things we can do to help us keep
our mental health active longer
like having good clinical health,
good health in general,
seeing the doctor regularly to control
cardiovascular factors,
control the blood pressure,
make sure that our diet is the
correct one, eat properly,
having a healthy diet
to avoid diabetes, to control diabetes.
Also, to control...when cholesterol
is high, the triglycerides.
Control factors that could contribute
to the cardiovascular factor,
which we know is working
alongside Alzheimer's,
and makes the symptoms more severe.
- Okay. And, as you were saying,
this disease is a really terrible disease
for the person affected by it but also for
their family. So what type of resources
exist for the person affected
and their families?
- Yeah, the resources that currently exist
include, for example,
we have the Southern Caregivers that
is an association that provide resources
and advice, particularly,
to the family members that take care
of the people with Alzheimer's disease.
Southern Care Givers is a resource.
Also, two other associations
are Alzheimer's San Diego,
an Alzheimer's Association in
San Diego, and Alzheimer's Association,
which is a larger Alzheimer's Association.
They have the resources and programs
in which they can help the patient and the
person taking care of the patient.
They provide information about how to have
a more social relationship
in the community, how to be more
communicated with other people who
have the disease. There are support
groups for people
with this disease and their families,
that offer social support for this.
- That's great! So there are many
opportunities to obtain resources.
- There are many opportunities here,
and there are several ways in which we are
trying to go directly into the community
to develop a healthy and trusting
relationship with the people with the
disease and their families.
Here we have program called
"The Promoters" program,
where there are people, individuals,
that are in charge of going into the
community and developing a relationship
and communication with the patients and
family members that suffer
from this disease.
- Okay. And with all
these current investigations
and with all of these new developments,
is there hope for a cure?
- I think, Alex, that there is.
I think there are. Mainly, initially,
we are… the goal is to,
in the beginning, slow it
down a little, little by little,
making the disease a slower process,
which can allow the person to have more
living years with a better life quality.
That is the goal that we have, and so,
progressively, we are looking for ways
of making the disease slower and slower,
to the point where we can have enough
scientific and medical ammo to get to a
point in which we would be able to stop
the disease. But to get to that point,
we require information about the
human population, including us Latinos,
we require communication
and collaboration, and it is a slow
process but I think that's how it is.
I think it is possible.
- Well, that's great.
We have to keep going
forward and maintaining hope to try to
solve this disease affecting us,
a terrible disease that affects the whole
family, not only the one that suffers it.
- Absolutely.
- Thank you, Dr. Lopez, for being with us,
and thanks to all of you for watching
this episode in Spanish of
the Brain Channel, and I'll see
you next time. Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪
Para más información:
uctv.tv/brain